dmdm hydantoin is considered a
formaldehyde releaser which doesn't
sound so healthy for your scalp and
there actually is a class-action lawsuit
going on right now just because
something sounds bad doesn't mean it is
bad the mountain high releasing
preservatives release tiny amounts of
formaldehyde to kill microorganisms in
your beauty products you know what else
releases tiny amounts of formaldehyde
pairs anyone can bring a class action
lawsuit it doesn't mean that the claims
are true remember the same eyes micro
tears one that got thrown out in court
there's never been any link found
between formaldehyde releases and hair
loss so this one is probably going to go
through and out as well ironically
formaldehyde can actually cross-link
hair proteins and make your hair
stronger it's not good for you if you
inhale large amounts but the tiny
amounts from your preservatives aren't
going to make a difference